(audience cheering) - That good!
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- Yeah, it's got the little
hoodie and everything.
- Little Chanel.
- Yes. I know.
Just a little Chanel.
- Little Chanel.
- It's nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Yeah, so thank you for coming
So, we're celebrating momma's day.
So what's like the best
memory of like your momma.
- My mom is great.
You know, she's a principal,
so she's all about giving back
and giving to the kids.
I think great advice that
my mom has always given me
is just to be yourself.
- Yeah
- Be yourself.
It's your greatest.
- It sounds like such a cliche thing
but I think it's really
hard for some people.
- It's so hard
- To be comfortable in their skin.
- Yeah, Was she ever your principal?
- No, my mom was never my principal.
I wanted her to be my principal so bad.
- You what?
- Cause I thought it was cool
but she was like, absolutely not.
- You are so rare.
Cause my mom was a teacher
and I didn't want her to
be in the same school.
I love my mom, but I was like, you know
teachers already kind of teach you
or they're different with you
when your mom's in the school.
Yeah. They're like watching you.
- Yeah,
- Not that I was doing anything.
- My mom didn't want the kids to talk bad
about her in front of me.
That was, I remember that
was the one reason why
she didn't want me to hear that?
- Oh my God.
You have such a sweet relationship.
Okay. So wait, we have a video of one
of your first performances
and this is real cute, so,
- Phenomenal girl, phenomenal girl.
That's me, Casey.
There's a greatness in me that
the world is waiting to see
and I will not disappoint them.
Phenomenal girl, phenomenal girl.
That's still me Casey.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my Gosh!
(audience clapping)
like I have little kids
and if my kid was up
there saying that, I swear
to God I'd buy her pony.
(laughs) Like I would be
like, what do you want?
I mean, that was so cute.
How old were you there
- I was five.
- You were five.
So wait, you're performing at,
at home or you at a school?
Where were you?
- Well, I always had a really
big personality and my mom's
a principal and nobody
in my family was ever
in the entertainment industry.
- Yeah
- So my parents were like, what
do we do with her? (laughs)
So, what do we do with this?
So my aunt, she ran a
pageant program and, that was
like me doing my monologue
at, at her badge.
It was my first time ever
doing something like that.
My first time ever really
performing in, in front of people.
- Do you remember being nervous
at all, or were you fine?
- No, I was, I was never
nervous as a child.
It only happened until
I got older. (laughs)
- Yeah, no, it's weird.
Cause I always ask people,
especially if you're
on stage doing something cause,
I was never nervous on stage
like singing, but I get
nervous in other situations.
- Well I used to get nervous before going
on stage and then when
you're on stage, it's like
- Oh it's like a, you come a lot.
You're like a different human almost.
Or maybe really you, I
don't know what this means.
- You went deeper.
- Yes. I went, maybe I went too deep,
but, so let's talk
about your current show.
So it's called Naomi.
I'm very into superhero thing.
All things superhero I'm very in.
So, you are in a
superhero now show, right?
- Yes.
- Is that what it is?
- Yes
- Okay. So what, who is Naomi?
- Naomi is a 16 year old
girl who loves Superman
which is really funny
cause it's a superhero show
and she loves Superman.
She's a big comic book fan.
She has the third biggest
Superman fan site in the world.
- Look how cute you are. What!
- (she laughs) Thank you, thank you
- Oh my gosh!
- She has the third biggest
Superman fan site in the world.
And then an event happens in
her town and Superman comes
and from there she figures
out her hidden destiny
and figures out how powerful
she really, really is.
- I'm in.
I love these things.
I love watching them with my kids too.
So wait.
So here's the comic book
the show is based on.
So you can see her character arc
in the covers from fan
to finding out who she is
and to being a part of
the superheros club.
So was this like a cool, were
you, are you a superhero fan
of things like this or was this
a cool role to get to play?
- When I got the audition,
I was like, whoever books,
this is gonna be like
really good for them.
I would love to see this.
And then it turned out to be
me, but I love this season,
thank you (audience cheering)
- I Love that.
- Thank you.
- That's so exciting.
- It's like whoever books
this, this is gonna be so
cool. And,
- It's like a fun dream role.
- It's a, it is a dream role.
And with miss Ava, the team, and
- It's rare that you're
playing like your age.
I always feel like people are always like
so I'm playing this person,
and never not their age.
It's like, oh you're actually the age.
That's amazing.
So your character has become
a role model for girls.
So is that, I know it has to feel good
but do you feel any pressure ever
cause you're like representing it?
- I, you know, you feel
pressure with everything.
I think me being authentically
I started the show when I was 16.
I'm 17, being that age
and then authentically being a black girl
and knowing that
experience, it really helps.
- Yeah.
- But I feel an honor to be
a part of the representation
and to even get DMs or messages
about my hair in the show
and how the braids represent
so many people in real life.
And they don't see that
reflected all the time
in the media is great.
- Aww, that's bomb, that's
rare. (audience cheering)